every horror film can't be a masterpiece
but beyond all those crappy sequels in
the straight-to-dvd track there are a
few films we describe as pretty much
perfect from stories about satanic cults
the films about possessed parents these
horror movies are practically flawless
what's more tragic choosing your own
destruction or being destined to fail
that's the question at the heart of
hereditary hailed as the scariest movie
of 2018 hereditary is certainly
frightening and it features one of the
most twisted endings in horror history
but the film offers a lot more than
scares and screams it's a disturbing
examination of family life the corrosive
power of grief and the crippling power
of mental illness mom what are you doing
yes the film features seances spirits
and what might be the creepiest cult
ever committed to celluloid yes the film
will keep you checking your ceiling for
months to come
and yes that scene involving a
sketchbook and a fireplace will cause
your jaw to hit the floor however the
real power of hereditary comes from the
sense of foreboding that lingers over
the entire film just like Tony Colette's
character builds miniature dolls and
tiny rooms it sometimes feels like our
lives are being manipulated by unseen
forces hereditary seems to suggest that
no matter how hard you try to escape
your past the traits you inherit will
haunt you forever if you've ever watched
the slasher film you know that only
virgins get out alive if the monster
catches you getting intimates he'll
introduce your face to mr. knife but
writer director David Robert Mitchell
decided to play with that old cliche and
it follows a horror film or having sex
can kill you but it can also keep you
alive this 2014 film involves a young
girl who contracts a supernatural STD
unless she passes it along she'll be
killed by a shape-shifting monster going
to a place that doesn't
it's very slow but it's not done if she
dies the creature will hunt down the guy
who gave it to her and so on and so
forth it feels like an actual urban
legend but this film is scarier than any
creepypasta that's because the movie
Monster is one of the most terrifying in
recent memory you can't reason with it
you can't outrun it like that it just
keeps coming you don't know when you
don't know how I rest assured it will
stagger into view sooner or later it's
as inevitable as growing old and as
relentless as time directed by Jennifer
Kent the babadook revolves around a
single mom named Amelia who's dealing
with the death of her husband plus her
extremely troubled six-year-old son
Amelia has been trapped in her grief in
depression for a while and things only
get worse when the babadook enters the
picture the demon is first introduced to
us in the pages of a pop-up book and
he's the personification of Amelia's
depression as she plunges deeper into
emotional darkness the babadook grows
stronger and stronger much like The
Shining the babadook wants you to
discuss its cryptic ending and try to
figure out what's real and what's not
is there a literal evil spirit trying to
possess amelia is it symbolic of her
pain the best thing about the babadook
is that the answer is yes and yes
horror-comedy is tough so many would-be
chillers wind up stumbling over their
own goofiness but sam raimi
the man behind the evil dead franchise
is a master at blending fear and fun
still not enough horror fans appreciate
drag me to hell
that's a shame because this 2009 film is
pitch perfect when it comes to melding
dark humor with genuinely disturbing
horror the plot follows a young woman
who's been cursed by a vengeful old
witch in three days Christine will be
dragged to hell and until then she'll be
haunted by a powerful demon this simple
plot lets Raimi indulge all his gross
out horror urges from eyes popping out
of cakes to wormy corpses it's a
grotesque ghoulishly fun romp that even
includes a foul-mouthed incredibly
fierce old goat
but Raimi pulls no punches when it comes
to the scares and drag me to hell
features one of the most frightening n
means you'll ever watch through your
fingers take Ridley Scott's cold
directing style and sigourney weaver's
badassery and you've got the freakiest
sci-fi movie ever made released in 1979
alien is a truly terrifying experience
everything you see on screen you can
just about feel on your skin no matter
how you slice it this is basically a
perfect horror film everything an alien
is just so viscous and violent and the
alien design is 12 it's out of this
world the xenomorph feels like something
that could exist in real life and the
film brilliantly exploits our
deep-seated fear of parasites the idea
of a creature crawling around your
innards is truly disgusting so when the
alien pops out of Kane's chest it's
still one of the most visceral horror
scenes ever filmed but aside from all
this monster talk let's not forget about
Weaver as Ellen Ripley
[Music]
[Applause]
while she became an icon in the sequel
Ripley establishes herself as a big-time
monster hunter an alien
long story short she's a horror hero for
the ages Wes Craven's and Nightmare on
Elm Street is a masterpiece of
surrealist horror it's about a
supernatural killer who gets you in your
sleep
and as the film goes on Kraven blends
the dream world with reality leaving you
to wonder where waking life ends and the
nightmare begins with his ratty sweater
and demonic glove Freddy Krueger is one
of the most frightening monsters to ever
haunt the silver screen and that's
because when you fall asleep he becomes
your God just like an actual dream there
are no rules in Freddy's world and when
the dreams start bleeding into the real
world
that's scary surrealism at its finest
everyone's scared of getting sick nobody
wants to look in the mirror and see
something they don't recognize staring
back that's why the fly packs such a
punch
directed by David Cronenberg this 1986
remake finds Jeff Goldblum playing
eccentric scientist Seth Brundle a man
whose morphing into a hideous insect
throughout the course of the film body
parts fall off grundles body he twitches
shakes and vomits all over his food his
humanity is rotting away and the insect
is taking over
Cronenberg has said the movie is an
allegory for AIDS but the metaphor also
works with everything from drug
addiction to aging the human body can't
last forever
that's why the fly is sure to linger in
your mind for many years to come as a
wise woman once said be afraid
there aren't any vampires or werewolves
in the Silence of the Lambs
instead this oscar-winning thriller is
about real-life monsters Hannibal Lecter
and Buffalo Bill are terrifying because
they could actually exist when Lecter
stares straight into the camera you're
looking into the eyes of a genuine demon
a monster you might actually meet on the
street childhood Jonathan Demi's movie
is steeped in gothic horror
Hannibal's dank cell and Buffalo Bills
dungeon look like layers you'd find in
an acre Allen Poe story the acting
matches the lurid styled with Anthony
Hopkins giving an electrifying
performance as the world's most charming
psychopath Jodie Foster provides the
perfect counter balance as Clarice
Starling the character is gritty and
ambitious and experienced but strong of
course
murderous cannibals will always be
pretty scary but the real horror is the
film's depiction of a woman living in a
male-dominated world Demi uses his
unique camerawork and incredible
composition to show Starling surrounded
by intimidating dudes from squaring off
with a room full of cops to her
nightmare showdown with Buffalo Bill
but she never backs down and her deathly
dance with Hannibal makes for one of the
most twisted relationships ever seen on
the big screen
plenty of horror movies provide blood
and guts but few horror movies actually
move you when it comes to tragedy
there's no horror film quite as
unsettling as Brian De Palma's Carrie
underneath all the pig blood and psychic
powers Carrie is ultimately a story
about a lonely soul an outsider who's
bullied so badly she finally breaks
sorry trust me Carrie
you can trust me [ __ ] Spacek gives one
of the best performances in horror
history is Carrie White
starting off as a terrified teen
morphing into a happy girl with a great
big smile then turning into a wide-eyed
telekinetic killer De Palma is at the
top of his game here he creates a high
school world that feels like something
out of a dream before it explodes into a
full-blown nightmare the prom bloodbath
is ingenious in its editing and camera
work with the director using every trick
in the book from slow motion and split
screens to lighting techniques straight
out of Italian giallo films the result
is a movie that's horrific to watch
because of the fright factor and the
loneliness at the heart of its titular
character poorer fans love to debate
which movie was the first real slasher
film was it Bay of blood or the Texas
Chainsaw Massacre perhaps it was black
Christmas whatever gory flick got things
started Halloween introduced slasher
films into the mainstream released in
1978 this brutal little thriller laid
the groundwork for every masked killer
movie that's come since but few films
have managed to capture the evil essence
of the original
[Applause]
[Music]
the moment you hear the halloween-themed
you want to look over your shoulder to
make sure someone isn't stalking you
then there's the chilling visuals like
the iconic point of view tracking shot
of Michael Myers his first kill who can
forget those brief glimpses of Michael
as he sets his sights on Laurie Strode
it's all so simple yet it touches upon
something primal at the end of the day
Halloween is all about the man in the
mask
he's the personification of evil and
cinemas biggest boogeyman no matter how
many times you kill him he keeps coming
back for more and so do we
Rosemary's Baby is a master class in
building suspense and unease but instead
of using mystery to create tension
director Roman Polanski lets us know
something devilish is happening pretty
much right off the bat Mia Farrow plays
rosemary Woodhouse a woman who gets
pregnant after a darkly trippy night so
that she can't quite remember soon after
it becomes clear that something wicked
is growing inside her womb meanwhile her
intensely creepy neighbors refused to
leave her alone where's your hubby do
he's an actor at first rosemary doesn't
understand what's happening but the
audience sure does yet the lack of
mystery never detracts from the suspense
in fact it makes it even more unbearable
as Roger Ebert wrote in his review when
the conclusion comes it works not
because it is a surprise but because it
is horrifyingly inevitable and what a
conclusion it is he has his father's
eyes the haunted house is a classic
horror archetype cinema is full of
spooky homes from The Amityville Horror
to poltergeist but few have captured the
creepy dread and terrible sadness of
living in a ghostly home like the
orphanage the story follows a woman
named Laura who buys an old orphanage
with the hopes of using it to help
disabled children but when her own son
disappears in its darkened corridors
Laura suspects there might be evil
spirits at play the movie takes its time
jarring you with disturbing images of a
creepy kid wearing an unsettling mask
and as Laura searches for her son and
digs deeper into her past
she learns that history is full of
ghosts always haunting the present and
sometimes asking for help check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite horror films or coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]